so what we're going to do in this video
is several examples where we evaluate
expressions with definite integrals and
so right over here we have the definite
integral from negative 2 to 3 of 2 f of
x dx
plus the definite integral from 3 to 7
of 3 f of x dx and all we know about f
of x is the graph of y equals f of x
from negative from x equals negative 6
to x equals 7 they also give us the
areas between f of x y equals f of x and
the x axis the negative areas show that
our function is below the x-axis and so
given that can we evaluate that and like
always pause the video and see if you
can do it on your own
well the first thing that my brain wants
to do is
i want to
i want to take these constants out of
the integral because then once they're
out and i'm just taking the straight up
definite integrals of f x i can relate
that to the areas over here and i know i
can do that and this is a very common
integration property it applies to
definite and indefinite integrals but if
i'm taking the integral of k
f of x
dx this is the same thing as k times the
integral of f of x
dx so let's just apply that property
there which is really you're taking the
scalar outside of the integral to say
this is going to be the same thing as 2
times the definite integral from
negative 2 to 3
of f of x
dx
plus
3 times the integral from 3 to 7 of f of
x
dx
all right now can we evaluate these
things
so what is
this going to be the definite integral
from negative 2 to 3 of f of x dx well
we can view that is the area between the
curves y equals f of x and the x axis
between x equals negative 2 and x equals
3. so between x equals 2 and x equals 3
they give us the area between y equals f
of x and the x axis it is 7. so this
thing over here is 7
and then we have the integral from 3 to
7 of f of x so we're going to go from 3
to 7
and once again well this this is going
to evaluate to a negative value because
f of x is below the x-axis there and
it's going to evaluate to negative three
so this is all going to be
this is going to be two times seven so
fourteen
plus
fourteen plus
three times negative three so plus
negative 9 and so 14 minus 9 is equal to
5. this is fun let's do more of these
all right
okay
so here
this first integral the integral from 0
to 5 of f x d of x so this is pretty
straightforward this right over here
we're going to go from 0 to 5
0 to 5
and of f of x d of x dx so we're talking
about this area there which they tell us
is 4. so that was pretty easy to
evaluate
and now we're going to subtract we're
going to subtract going from negative 8
to negative 4 times 2 f of x
well let's just take this 2 outside
so if we just take this 2
outside
then this just becomes the integral from
negative 8 to negative 4 of f of x and
so this thing
this thing right over here evaluates to
5 it's this area they're talking about
so this is all going to simplify to 4
minus that 2 that we brought out
minus 2 times 5
times 5 which is equal to
let's see 4
minus 10 which is equal to negative 6.
all right let's do another one of these
so here i have the integral from
negative seven to negative five so i'm
going from negative seven
to negative five which is it's going to
be right around there so i wanna find
i wanna find
this area
right over here
so i want to find that area that's that
and then i'm going to go from negative 5
to 0.
so then this is going to be going from
negative 5
to 0. so it's going to be
all of that now there's a couple of ways
you could think about doing it you could
assume i have some symmetry here and
they don't tell it for sure but it looks
very symmetric around x equals negative
five so you can assume that this eight
is split between these two regions but
an easier way to do it is just to
realize look i'm going from negative
seven to negative five and then from
negative five to zero and i'm
integrating the same thing f of x dx so
this integral i can rewrite as the
integral from negative seven
so negative seven all the way to zero
of f of x
f of x dx and so really that's just
going to be the net area between
negative 7 and 0. and so we have the
positive 8 there so this is going to be
equal to the positive 8 and then we have
the negative 1 there so minus 1 which is
equal to 7.